unnecessary forcing of the universal
logo onto car wheel is unnecessary these
jackasses are yelling and making all
kinds of noise while rushing out when
they'd be safer just being quiet and
going at a normal speed it is really
owns a garage and worked on cars you
might expect his outfit to be a little
dirtier but what you don't know is this
is his formal jumpsuit Lily is a dick to
people with epilepsy
even though Sookie is one of the four
races tonight she's wearing an insane
outfit more conducive to a slow mo
grinding dance montage than a street
race
Sookie's pit crew consists of two people
who barely know how to use chamois
towels sexual assault now where has your
fourth bag can someone remind me why we
need four drivers for this race is it to
force awkward character introductions
want to race tonight yeah you know I
could use money
okay so Bryan needs money so why hasn't
he been able to get in any street races
why is he just now being called about
this awesome street race you know why I
think he's not already there the movie
wanted to make Bryan's entrance more
dramatic hello the guy lives in teches
garage so it's not like these guys are
mere acquaintances you waste time with
one I can only assume is exhibits wet
dream Miami in addition to being a huge
city of over two million people is also
dead empty everywhere you go because
Miami is boring no one calls the cops on
this loud invasive group of assholes
that illegally blocked off roads in a
semi urban area nobody said nothing got
my rights in the state Bryan comes into
the last minutes just raising the stakes
and suddenly everybody has to raise the
stakes just because he said so and while
Bryan needs money he can apparently
plunk down $3,500 on a goddamn car race
inside lodge even I don't even go home
why do all four of them have at least
$3,500 on hand I get they're criminals
but this still seems like an
irresponsibly large amount of money to
keep on your person when you gonna top
my class schedule certainly eat his
words when Sookie grants the head of his
penis and jerks it like a collector you
know it might be helpful if they had any
idea how this course is mapped out to
get more involved with this race as is
it's just pricing shipping blurriness
nobody expects me to believe that all
these streets are empty when all these
stoplights are disabled because a group
of people at a pickup truck put up a
road closed on Oh
Sookie's car top is down in her hair is
an out-of-control blowing in her face
and she's able to audibly scream
expletives at other drivers this guy
just hit the nos button but act
surprised when his car starts going
faster wait does the nonce take a car to
hyperspace hit it baby hey tej not only
knows someone who can make a drawbridge
go up in the middle of the night but
also
knows how to kill for street racers with
his moon flapjack is only going over 100
then seconds later Bryan hits the nos
and his blasting past 160 how is
slapjack not eating Bryan stuffed these
jars don't nosedive into the pavement
stopping them immediately and killing
the drivers instantly this wreck is
brought to you by I forgot what company
it is also wasn't he just going close to
100 miles an hour
how's he not dead you know we can you
can work on that front and be yours this
rate tej may run out of sexual car puns
perfect timing despite everyone getting
pinned in by cops as they try to escape
street race central Bryan apparently has
some heretofore unknown secret exit out
of this place so he can outrun the cops
who she's Foss is apparently designing
weapons for the FBI Carter Verone born
in Argentina expedition will can't
breathe in cliche if I don't here's a
list of the laws you've broken la bubi
assumes that if it triple X's itself a
little bit we won't notice that Vin
Diesel isn't in it oh do you better
motor for my skyline a Gallo as well or
Gallo 2424 and in no pizza places made
motors why is it in movies that the FBI
is somehow this incompetent when it
comes to undercover work like they can't
find anybody who knows cars and the
entirety of the bureau that's boy in
Monte Carlo agent bilkins doesn't
already know this he's crazy as out
sounds like just the kind of liability
that the FBI loves to take on the front
of Romans charismatic there's no way he
could get the nose of his car under this
station wagon enough to flip it also
this ridiculous redneck demolition derby
doesn't prove he's a good driver in the
slightest
it proves he's an idiot for not wearing
a helmet blondie has not a cop anymore
that's true no badge Roman asked bilkins
this question like he knows that bilkins
is a cop who can corroborate Brian's
previous statement as Roman and Brian
fight here I wonder do you think this
was the best guy to get to the job sure
he can play a street racer no problem
but work for the cops he could have
probably asked any number of people to
do this job and it would have been
better than this guy that's like the
fourth or fifth good punch Rome has
gotten in during this fight yet Brian's
face remains unscathed I need you to
come to Miami and drive with me if you
do they'll take off that anklet and
accrue your entire record I did three
years in jail I know you better than you
think they're still legit Roman from
dismissing Brian's request because he's
a habitual betrayer to you being
interested in the deal in literally 15
seconds I thought you couldn't wander
more than 100 yards from your home why
you think I'm parked so close to the
Derby
god dammit did they really expect me to
believe that a judge sentenced a man to
house arrest who lives in a mobile home
that's not how sir
it's just being completely free because
you can drive that booking thing
anywhere also how the put this even work
those ankle monitors rely on geofencing
which is fixed to a specific location
it's not a magical anklet that can tell
you when you walk a certain distance
away from a Winnebago they would have to
put a tracking device in his mobile home
in order see how far away he is from but
unless they arrest the thing for aiding
and abetting that would be extremely
unfair to an innocent Winnebago I don't
know if I should be trusted was Roman
has some outstanding warrants the movie
forgot to tell us about we've
established these aren't crooked cops
unless you count hiring former criminals
whose only marketable skills driving
well to do their undercover work as
crooked so why is he worried because he
think they're going to arrest him for
something he's already served jail time
for I would need a fresh start from one
view if we established that Rome blames
Brian for his criminal record we have
three times in the last five minutes
okay great just checking I'm not going
back wash though takes Rome in a matter
of seconds to overcome any objections he
has to going through with this deal it's
almost as if this movie is just
manufacturing all this bullshit conflict
in Monica Fuentes wearing her standard
police-issue 60 Plus also Monica either
opted to or was forced to ride standing
in the back of this truck which is
refrigerated for maximum sexiness
they've been briefed all right here's
the deal
never mind I'm going to brief you anyway
22 Digambar taking the convertible
because it's less aerodynamic and an
open cabin causes lots of drag at high
speeds
wait it's because he wants it for
himself he shoots standard driving down
the road like it's a chase scene these
two are supposed to be badass street
racers driving badass fast cars then
explain to me why they just got passed
by a Ford Explorer tonight here if your
undercover cops posing a street racers
you need to have a prestige level of
commitment to the bit and do Street
research on the way to the meeting this
is an easy trick if you're not actually
driving you did this there drive on you
didn't Roman and Brian pulled that
frequently enough for it to have a name
muevete adds runtime with 30 more
seconds of car park wedgies even cause
the bottom of a cereal box
semi illegitimate burn makes me wonder
why the FBI opted to go with Japanese
sports cars instead of springing for
some nice American muscle cars Carter is
the proud owner of our golden diesel
that he uses to hold the apparently
wireless monitor that displays his
surveillance system also the number of
camera views displayed here suggests
that Carter has 12 cameras around his
property but at least two of the views
displayed at the same I don't know who
Carter is trying to impress here but he
would have been better served by
swallowing his pride and just displaying
four views on the smaller screen it's
good to see the Smash Mouth couldn't
make it to the street race meeting long
time and the cops in Miami must be up to
their ears and cocaine busts to miss all
these tricked-out sleds gunning it down
I'm glad they paid all that money to
animate this otherwise I'd have no idea
the FBI is tracking the we're about to
the car they owned it's being used in an
undercover operation
they're running quite a surprise I put
Markham think they were running even if
he is being up at his job not to assume
the obvious here Monica would definitely
have told him that there would be some
kind of a test and that this is all part
of the plan Roman Brian and all the
other drivers slow down to the flow of
traffic just so they can have this
playful moment just before they start
weaving through traffic again this gem i
doesn't stop before this happens yeah
they race finally earns his paycheck in
this movie running into this doesn't
burn scar or Brian there we go you're
just now checking up on Romans
credentials Rover decides to read up on
Roman Pearce is going to be confused
because it talks about Brian here and
then suddenly switches pronouns to see
here and here gonna set up look in the
center package is in the center console
instead of in the glovebox which is
where Carter said it would be cops they
how they doin here I mean right it's
such a free-for-all in Miami the
criminals can do outreach like this and
still question why cops are here also
yeah why are the cops here yeah he
thinks Roman and Brian are running but
you've got to be kidding me with this
mess their cars have GPS trackers and
you can find them anytime then why take
the risk of thing up an investigation
why not at least hang back and see what
they're up to before going insane
the thing Barone doesn't check this
thing because what's with April 8 this
guy has five speeding tickets on April
8th and three and one day in 1992 twice
he got careless driving violations on
Valentine's Day in 1982 even though he
was born in 1973 that's a nine year old
carelessly driving also I find it
tremendously endearing that one day in
1991 the cops pulled over this man for a
seatbelt violation he must have been
totally going the speed limit that day
what's he checking her out for I'm not
shaking around she can't hear this yes
you were
no was it and now you're still arguing
about this bull I mean yes he was
checking her out Tyrese was checking her
out I was checking her out this whole
pile is out of order
Erica oh my god I don't care how rich
you are it's a waste to throw away a
perfectly good barely smoked cigar as a
sheet is barking out stuff through a
megaphone at his garage where he's an
ace street car mechanic I wonder how he
became such an amazing computer hacker
in the later movies I gotta do it I am
every day though when in law enforcement
seems to be upset that edge is running
illegal gambling outside of his business
and that he's clearly using his garage
to launder the money he makes from this
jet ski racing skiing I mean it's pretty
clear that only one dude is actually
doing any work on cars I hit a wall
doing like a buck 20 couple years ago
not because I'm a member of the fast and
furious team and didn't have a Wonder
Woman movie to do I didn't die from that
both of them a lot like I never seen
before what how the actual was Roman
surprised the FBI is tracking them all
so why do they care that the FBI is
tracking them wasn't the whole deal for
them to work with the FBI to bring down
Carter so they could get their records
cleaned if they ripped out the tracking
info from their cars that would mean the
deal is off right right and when they've
been honest ever since we left the room
tonight and instead of losing them much
earlier Brian decided to lead them right
to the place where they plan to hide out
to these federal agents forget the old
idiom those who meet in mostly glass
restaurants should not meet with
undercover operatives because passers-by
can see them meeting with you I think
that's how it goes what's just about man
it couldn't be about that time I shot at
you 20 times right you think she's
compromised you should know your old pal
O'Conner didn't tell you he flipped on
bilkins in LA gave his mark his car keys
and let him disappear so because
O'Conner did this in the first movie he
should know of Monaco's in the drug load
why is my n able to shut down during
impromptu street races - doesn't market
modify these cars to use NAS as
ludicrous speed seems appropriate for
some reason let's see we got the fall
given how fast they're both traveling
and how far away they are from each
other i severely doubt that Fonzie would
have enough time to even say good move
kid before Brian cracked into him
head-on
Brian successfully gets this guy to
swerve off course for a second but he's
still way way way behind and will
somehow bolt way back to neck and neck
with this asshole just because of an off
movie continues to act like hitting the
nitrous button and going over a hundred
miles an hour is the same as the
Millennium Falcon making the jump to
Lightspeed murders Club is a magical
fantasy told up in ancient legends that
contains more women than men
it's the hallways in here that's how
Isis what is the feel he doesn't trust
people to carry badges
brian says this right in the middle of
Carter Barone's club while they're both
undercover because he is very interested
in getting them all killed I've been a
cop about two months
when Roman was busted in a garage raid
and I missed the day where they tell you
not to talk about being a cop while
undercover also movie decides now is the
time to explain why Roman was so mad at
Brian when they met up earlier in the
film explaining it then when it made
more sense to do so would have been too
easy
I wanted risk touching we all know what
that leads to hand-holding which can get
you pregnant
why is this such big news didn't Barone
invite them here is over there don't
look even though he's clearly staring at
you guys right now and notices you're
here so play it cool Hahnemann why does
this even need to be said didn't he
specifically asked for them to come to
his little VIP room five minutes of her
time and she can get anything she wants
from Carter is so brilliant he was able
to figure out that attractive women can
use their sexuality to manipulate weak
men who do I got a problem with
authority I have that same problem for
me it's cops
for me it's firemen they're all like get
out of the house it's on fire and I'm
like I don't have to listen to you Pig
oh you know I just carry around a rat
anywhere I go just in case there's
somebody I want to torture at a moment's
notice once the bucket gets hot enough
detective all right it's going to want
out only direction it can go this south
this overly complicated torture
technique is basically here to show what
a sadistic bastard this guy is but it's
insane waste of time and rats rat can
just torture by rat in a heated bucket
just got a whole lot sexier oh yeah all
right John Albarn why not just do that
sleep around I'm a low-budget mechanic
but I overcharge me sure just start
raking in the pot before Ted even shows
his cards why you haven't been shot
playing poker yet is beyond me taka rise
wake Royal Flush hedge totally slow
rules is employing to under both these
guys haven't been shot playing poker and
a Royal Flush come on look it's a Royal
Flush when the stakes are highest except
Asian James Bond
imma crash says I kiss you tomorrow what
was the point of this entire scene
monitor wet right now because she swam
to Brian's house boat or did she get
there a normal way but the scene wasn't
sexy enough so they dumped a bucket of
water on her once she finished the run
they're putting a bullet in your head
why the fuck is she going to Brian about
this did she forget she's a customs
agent working with the FBI
she clearly risking her own life by
sneaking onto Brian's houseboat given
that Carter said us
touch another mannequin and I'll kill
you you think it'd be in everyone's best
interest for Monica to go and tell the
team of federal agents she works for
about this instead of going directly to
Brian but that wouldn't be nearly as
romantic and probably a lot less damp
they don't know I'm here I work out and
besides me not being there and no one
having any idea where I am and Carter
being suspicious that there's something
going on between me and Brian there was
no reason for them to be here there's a
skylight above the bathroom out the
peeping Tommy also this movie is going
to have us believe that Monica can
somehow lift herself through this window
without making any noise or rocking the
boat a little or she's dead is what I'm
saying
all of them are dead I'm going to remove
three sins because Eva Mendes exists and
you remember us growing up that
transition into this attempt at
emotional character development just
gave me whiplash
I got verone's navigator Lisa residence
the FBI has guys on the inside of
Barone's place but only when it's
convenient to the plot this guy is
checking in at his office so we can see
pictures of his family allowing the
viewer to remember his internal conflict
move on a trailer property right now
okay so I understand the Barone paid
this guy off to keep a window open for
his guys to deal the money but my
question is why is the cop know about
this operation at all looks like they
could have stolen this money without any
cop involved unless this is a place
where cops were already scoping out and
we're waiting for Verona to take the
money out but this movie has never
explained this money or why he hid in a
wall in a random house or why the cops
are involved
after that SUV stayed in a straight line
without anyone gripping the steering
wheel sure did
let's get the chopper over them on one
eye is right on top no one in the local
police department questions why an FBI
chopper is also chasing these guys this
weapon which is clearly complete bull is
only stuck to the door yet still messes
up all the inner workings of the car
I guess it's sending its bullsh bolts to
the Bulls commoner inside the cars both
Peredur which is causing everything to
go haywire
Brian conveniently pulls out the car
stopper hook it's the very last second
and apparently you don't even need a gun
to fire this thing into a car you just
need a good throwing arm and even though
the hook of this thing basically shut
the car completely down before Brian
removed it the car still works just fine
even after it's removed and I would love
to actually watch this car chase but I
guess seeing extreme close-ups of gas
pedals eyeballs and gear ships will do
just fine
the police don't immediately start
yelling at these assholes to come out
with our hands up cops don't immediately
start shooting at these asshole
there are seriously this many street
racers who could help out with operation
confuse the cops today must've lost them
in the scramble for some reason night at
the local police nor the FBI used their
resources to block the entrances and
exits to this facility preventing anyone
from escaping and then start arresting
those fools for whatever they can
definitely arrest them for all right we
got them going west on beat Hill
consultant assume they ditched those
cars and are now using them as a decoy
because that's what I a normal person
who is not an FBI agent assuming they're
doing okay so Roman and Brian switched
cars but aren't tears and Sukie in
serious trouble for aiding and abetting
why so happy and with all the goddamn
cars you guys just threw at the cop so I
even bother driving these sure you get
them teasing after cars that don't
actually have the money but with all the
confusion you could have just kept these
cars parked in the garage so what's
their plan here the money isn't showing
up so I guess they're just gonna arrest
their own for almost getting onto his
own plane where's the rest of it yeah
the car another car right another car
how do you not know didn't you have this
master plan to provide Roman and Brian
with one goon each to go with them when
they got the money I did not know
there's another car Nadia not know
something happened one of them and then
this asshole decides he's going to leave
without the other half of his money for
some reason without any other
explanation so you know nothing about
the agents that store my jet so if you
don't know about the other car how do
you know about this they arrested the
guys that were out there right did the
feds give them all their one phone call
and they used it to call Verone and tell
him about the jet Justin H is sure
getting pretty how does he know that
she's a customs agent I'm sure he could
assume that she's informing the police
based on what she knows and what the
cops now know but he knows her exact
role did the screenwriter whisper to him
because there are only seven minutes
left in the movie
get on home no idea why Barone doesn't
just kill Monica and Brian right here in
that this is a guy doesn't even have to
think twice about heating up a rat and a
metal pail to torture a dude but he
can't just kill some fools take his
money and leave what's that
who cares just kill him already Roman
Han Solo's in at the last minute and
announces himself over the walkie just
before Brian gets shot they're really
gonna try and pull this Duke so deep
that he beat me to it
that yacht probably maxes out at maybe
50 miles an hour I'm Brian and Roman are
going 90 somehow they don't whiz past
the boat and just shoot off into the
water if I know there was a ramp here if
so how so also it just happens to be a
perfect place to fly his car into the
boat that wraps anywhere else this
ending doesn't happen also they survived
this some both guys with guns on this
boat don't come up and shoot both these
assholes dead or they're dead and the
movie didn't tell us that dad and just
made us assume that even though their
own has the drawn them Brian's still
managed to shoot first downstairs the
screenwriter was fighting off the
remaining guards and vigorously untying
Monica so she could make it back up here
just in time to conveniently take the
gun from burrow open a garage together I
was gonna do that breast pocket Tina
because Ryan says this like he's got
some big surprise for Roman here but
Roman has some of the money stuff down
in his jeans so why did he think opening
up a garage would be hard to do when
he's got stacks of cash in his pants
but rah-rah breath breath breath breath
there is the second position where is
y'all know me like that hey where did
you get those clothes at the toilet
store man took your Ferrari online be
sure to me
I'm a cop you're in federal aid I am an
FBI agent long about now that that boy
wishes he had a parachute like a piece
of cake that was awfully close there
Hoss loved American Muscle
I'm gonna go take a piss that's a little
bit more information I'm using suppose
[Music]